the problem with the concept of the
power of positive thinking is people
just think oh well if I just have
positive thoughts then my life should be
affected and and this is why positive
thinking has a real bad rap in the
public and the reason is this having a
positive thought does not in any way
necessitate that those positive thoughts
actually manifest themselves and there's
a piece that was left out and if you
don't understand the peace then you're
shouting into the wind with your
positive thoughts nothing's going to
happen and the fact is this when you're
having positive thoughts you're using
your mind the new biology reveals that
the invisible forces that collectively
we refer to as mine that these form a
field which shape biology here's what's
important yes the Mind influences
biology but there are two parts to the
mind that are completely different than
one another yet they work together we
confuse them we tie them together and
yet they represent two entities working
in two different Fashions there's the
conscious mind and what is called the
subconscious mind
hey it's Evan Carmichael and I make
these videos because in my first
business I was making 300 bucks a month
I quit on my business partner and the
thing that saved me was studying the
stories of super successful
entrepreneurs so I hope that this story
today helps give you the motivation you
need because I still needed to myself so
today let's learn the mindset shift you
need to activate the Law of Attraction
enjoy
here's what the very important people
have to know this okay and here's what
it is the conscious mind is our creative
mind that is connected to our personal
identity and our spiritual selves that's
that makes us all unique or each of us
has our own personal conscious mind but
what becomes very significant is this is
the subconscious mind is equivalent to a
tape player it's exactly what it is it
records experiences and then plays them
back
and and so now let's take a look and say
well wait there's a thinking mind and
then there's a tape player mind and
what's different about them is very
profound so let's talk about two
fundamental differences first
the tape player the subconscious mind
as an information processor as the
equivalent of a computer is a million
times more powerful on an information
processor than it's a conscious mind so
when you look at the power between the
conscious and subconscious subconscious
a million times more powerful number two
on a date by day basis
the subconscious mind runs our biology
about 95 to 99 percent of the time
so while you're having all these
wonderful thoughts that's not the
conscious the conscious mind's not
running the show it's a subconscious
mind
then comes the issue is well the
subconscious mind got programs in it yes
and and the subconscious mind is not
evil or good the subconscious mind is a
tape player as much as you can say okay
here here's a tape player it's good or
bad so the tape player is not good or
bad
the programs can be good and the
programs can be bad so blaming the
subconscious mind as a negative thing is
that's the first mistake it's a tape
player
programs that we got that's the source
of the problems that most of us face and
these programs could limit our abilities
and take away our powers which
essentially they do
now the relevance about positive
thinking is this
positive thinking is a creative thought
that comes from the conscious mind
okay so I sit here and I'm going to have
all these wonderful thoughts I'm going
to close my eyes and visualize all these
wonderful things now stop and go back to
to the the mechanical character of it a
I'm having these thoughts with a little
tiny processor called the conscious mind
and I'm competing with the programs that
are in the subconscious mind
so if I have a thought for uh being
being healthy or being in a good
relationship
and I'm doing positive thinking and at
the same time I have acquired programs
in my development that said you're not
as healthy as you think you are and you
you're not that good a person to have
those kind of relationships then look
I'm now pitting my positive thoughts
against my programs and and they're in
their opposite
but this one works on a little tiny
processor and this processor is a
million times more powerful so right
away it's like who's going to win in
that challenge the answer of course is
subconscious gonna win okay but here
comes the other part
while I can try to maintain positive
thoughts in my life using my conscious
mind this conscious mind only operates
less than five percent of the day that
says 95 or more of the day I'm operating
from the other belief system
the point is do the math
how powerful or positive thoughts and
the answer is unless the subconscious
has the same programs and agreement as a
conscious mind power of positive
thinking will not work
it will not work because you're
competing against a much more powerful
processor the belief that is taught is
that biology in the world we live in
operates according to Newtonian
principles uh unfortunate part about
that is quantum mechanics 100 years ago
said that's obviously not true and
physicists know this is not true and yet
medicine doesn't buy into it because it
still focuses on the material reality
and lets go of the invisible shaping
fields that quantum physics emphasizes
as primary okay so we got we have to
change that belief system we have to get
people to recognize that the field and
the thoughts and all these other things
are as important as anything else in
shaping the matter we live in uh number
two uh the belief which I you know I
blew away years ago but it's still being
taught in school is the concept that
genes control life
this is totally false genes control
nothing control is an action
a gene is a blueprint it's a physically
literally a string with blueprint data
on it why is that relevant well it's
interesting go to an architect's office
and The Architects working on a
blueprint and then lean over the
architectural and say is that blueprint
on or off and he looks at you wait
there's a blueprint's not on or off it's
a blueprint yeah but we talk about genes
being on and off like genes are turning
on and jeans are turning off and the
question is but genes are blueprints
they can't turn on and off there is no
on and off it's just the blueprint it's
a pattern what we have failed to focus
on because we gave genes a character of
self-actualization that my genes decided
to do something it's like okay now we're
a victim of the genes but it turns out
biologists know that this is not true
biologists know that genes are not
turned on and off genes are red or not
red like blueprints then all of a sudden
it says well it's not the blueprint
that's important if the blueprints were
self-actualizing an architect could go
by a building site drop the blueprints
off come back two weeks later and the
building will be there that's what we
think about animals and plants the genes
are Blueprints and their control all
this is like no the blueprints are
important I'm not saying they're not you
got the bad blueprints you got some
problems going on here but the issue is
it's not the presence or absence of a
blueprint it's whether the blueprint is
being read and then you say well then
who reads the blueprint the answer is a
contractor
and who's a contractor
the mind is the contractor the Mind
reads genes the mind can change the
genes read out here here's something so
blow away that most people can't in
their conventional World make sense of
it because it's it's like ah it goes
like this
the Mind through what is called
epigenetic mechanisms
can start with a single Gene blueprint
and create over 30
000 different versions of products from
the same blueprint thirty thousand
different products from the same
blueprint all of a sudden you realize my
God the you can infinitely vary the
expression of the Gene and the answer is
yes
and why is this become relevant to all
of us and the answer is because many of
us think genes control our lives and yet
we don't realize that we modify the read
out of the gene so we could be totally
healthy and our mind can cause cancer
our mind can cause any disease diabetes
anything like that and and what's
interesting is the flip side is some
people come here with actually defective
genes and guess what with their mind
they can rewrite those genes and make
them normal so the genes are not the
limiting factor it's the Mind shift
number two is believe with Ernest Holmes
this evening I am going to talk to you
about a powerful good in the universe
greater than you are
greater than I am greater than all of us
a powerful good that we can use
in everyday life for everything
when the greatest teacher who ever lived
said it is done unto you as you believe
what do you suppose he was talking about
this Mastermind
was talking about a spiritual power in
the universe something so close to us
that it is indeed nearer
than our hands and feet closer to us
than our very neck brain as the old
talmud said
and so this power is not something we
have to go in search after it is
something that is right here close
nearer than our very breath
how then would we use the power that is
so intimate
suddenly we should have to use it in an
intimate way
and we would certainly have to believe
that the power exists it's Forest not
against us it is willing and not
reluctant we should actually have to
believe that it really is done unto us
as we believe
then we would have to believe
what is belief anyway these other things
I want to discuss with you tonight
how it is that we could use this power
for good greater than we are wonderful
the thing the whole world wants more
than anything else in the world
the thing that you and I have
for the taking for the asking for the
using
power that responds to us according to
our conviction in it
power that is used in our own mind in
our own thinking
right where we are
how close and how intimate such a power
is
and how wonderful it is
just to believe
that we're going to learn how to use it
first of all just what it is then we're
going to talk about how to use it
then we are going to actually get right
down and use it
in our everyday life
first of all
the power of it is bigger than you are
and greater than I am is of course a
spiritual power
just what do we mean by a spiritual
power
we mean something that
is invisible of course
we don't see it
we don't touch it we don't taste it we
don't handle it we don't weigh if we
don't measure it
but we do feel it
just as you feel beauty just as you feel
loved just as you feel anything in life
this power greater than we are is a
powerful good
in response to us
if we have faith and confidence in it
not throughout all the ages people of
course have prayed and their plans have
been answered they're prayed with faith
it doesn't make any particular
difference what kind of a religion they
have had
that power has responded to everyone
in the way he has used it
that is why Jesus said
very simply very directly
it is done unto you as you believe
let us then analyze
the saying of Jesus
that it is done unto you as you believe
and suppose in doing that
that we pause after this little word as
seems like such an insignificant word
but it's the key to the teaching of this
great master
first of all he said it is done
by a power greater than you are
it is done unto you
by this power you don't do it
who has the power to create life
you and I did not make life
we did not create it
we did not think of ourselves
we awoke to the fact that we live
and we looked about and wondered
what in the world is it all about why am
I here
is there anything in the universe great
enough and good enough
to come to my rescue when I needed
quietly if I'm disturbed
to bring peace to my mind if I am this
quiet
is there really
power in the universe greater than I am
and is it good
and can I use it
Jesus said
it is done unto you
there is a power
that operates for you
and how does it operate
it operates as you believe
[Music]
I suppose we try to analyze just what do
we mean by belief
excuse the thing but it's very important
we do not believe a thing just because
we affirm it
I might say I believe bear is an
eloquent here but there isn't any
elephant
I might say there is thunder and
lightning here but I know there isn't
belief is something that our own mind
does not doubt it is something that we
ourselves
inwardly do not deny
you can tell right off
if you believe what you're saying
Shakespeare caused one of his characters
to say my words fly upward
my thoughts remain below words without
thoughts cannot
to Heaven go so you and I do not have to
very very much to see do I believe
that there is a power
greater than I am why of course we
believe it
some mysterious thing
which we call gravitational force
holding you and I in place right now
where you sit in your home
I'm standing here by this podium
I do not wonder whether or not this
power is going to hold me in place
I walk a little to the right or to the
left
I changed my position always I am
certain
there is a power greater than I am
holding me in place physically
now all I have to do is just to
transpose this and say
there's another kind of a power
it is greater than I am
it responds to my belief my faith my
confidence in it
and as soon as I established this then I
must be certain
that I actually believe
now probably this is the key to the
answer to every prayer that was ever
apart answered since time began
the prayer of faith of conviction
again the great teacher the great
metaphysician the great way Shore
he said when you pray
believe that you already have what
you're asking for
you know Jesus didn't say uh
God of his power be displeased if you
for a loaf of bread and as a matter of
fact he fed the multitude
he did not say God of his power doesn't
wish I have any uh enjoyment in life
he spoke of a joy
which would complete ours
he said it is done unto you
but as you believe
therefore he said when you pray
believe that you have
just believe that you have is it so hard
to believe that we have
we believe that tomorrow will come
we believe that the sun will rise in the
morning and set it night
we believe that the ocean and the tide
will be there and the Moon
we believe the grass will grow
We Believe
that our food will digest
and who is there who knows
how any of these things happen
did you ever stop to pay
that the United intelligence of the
human race
all the scientists living
all the philosophers
all the theologians
everybody
put together
does not know how it is
that a hen
can lay an egg
not as it know how it is that a chicken
can come out of an egg
that amazing
all we know is we set the hand
and the chicken does come out of the egg
this is the Mystery of Life
this is the mystery of faith
the power greater than we are
Jesus did not say
what is your particular religion
spoke to every man
in his own language
just believe
and it will be done unto you shift
number three is create a mood board with
Marissa peer many many years ago I was
trying to get a book deal and I'd put on
a little talk about how to lose weight
because my book was all about that and I
hadn't sold hardly any tickets so I
canceled it and the same day my agent
called me went oh my gosh I've got
um six different uh Publishers who want
to come to your talk I'm like well I
just can't this one put it back on quick
because they're all coming and it was
that weekend and I think she called me
on a Thursday night
so on the Friday I rang all my friends
everyone said come to this talk it's
completely free and and I got lots of
people to come because I knew that six
major publishing houses were coming to
this talk and she told me one of them
was definitely going to give me a deal
if not all of them so I only had Friday
and on Friday I could have spent ages
planning the talk but you know I didn't
I actually made a mood board I thought
that's a good thing so on Friday night I
had an old picture and I took it out of
the frame and I started to stick things
in it and I wrote Marissa Pier gets a
great book deal like I cut out the times
uh best-selling list and I stuck it in
there and wrote on it my book you can be
thin and I did lots and lots of pictures
that Marissa makes people thin I went
through magazines I cut stuff out I
wrote some checks out there I made this
mood ball really exciting and I just
looked at it and looked at it and looked
at it and it made me so excited about my
talk and the next day I went off and I
did the talk and lo and behold at the
end somebody came up to me and she said
oh my God I love that talk and we want
you to come in on Monday and we're going
to offer you a book deal straight away
and we'd really love you not to meet the
other five Publishers we want you so
that was very exciting and in fact I did
end up signing with them and it all was
wonderful but I know it was that mood
board that helped me because it took my
mind to where I wanted to be it made me
Focus only on success of course a mood
board doesn't say things like well I
might not make it the mood board has
success so let's imagine you want to be
a therapist
that's what your vision is or a
photographer maybe you want to be a chef
I want you to imagine you've got a mood
board and you fill it up with pictures
if you want to be a chef pictures of
great food reviews from restaurants and
of course you're going to cross out the
name of the chef and write your name in
and said in black marker pen so find
lots of reviews and put your name in and
then right all over the mood board too
let's say your name is Alexandra
Richardson you're going to put Alex
Richardson instead of that chef and
you're going to put lots of reviews and
let's say you've found
uh the top 10 best restaurants and
you're going to call your restaurant the
fox and so you cross that and you put
the fox Alex Richardson's restaurant the
fox and just keep looking at that and
you write all over your mood but all the
things that work for you people love
this restaurant the best restaurant in
wherever you live in the world the food
here is amazing and then you look at
lots of interviews with chefs and you
imagine your interview and you put it up
there you can even mock one up that's
what
printers have also mock up an interview
mock up everything and look at that mood
board mock up all the things that you're
going to cook they're going to give you
pleasure mock up the cookery book you're
going to write mock up so much stuff you
know a couple of years ago I was asked
to work with probably the angriest kid
I've ever worked with in my life and
when we started to work he said you know
no one loves me I have no love in my
life and I realized that his anger was
actually incredible pain but I talked to
him
and I asked him what he was good at he
said nothing so asked him what he loved
he said cooking so we talked about that
a bit and he's ended up being a
phenomenally successful Chef he's got a
great girlfriend
he went to work for other chefs he's now
got his own restaurant his life has
changed dramatically because I found one
thing that he loved and focused on his
purpose
and the reason he was here and he loved
cooking so much that I knew straight
away that that's what he was meant to do
and now he's doing it his life has
changed 360 Degrees mood boards have
been proven over and over again to
stimulate your brain to excite your
imagination to keep your focus on where
you want to go
when you focus on where you want to go
you actually go towards it the more you
focus on where you want to be the more
your mind like a heat-seeking missile
takes you to where you want to be
so if you want to be an Olympic Athlete
you'd have to take a lot of action you
have to practice a lot and train a lot
if you don't want to do something
physical
train your mind practice with your mind
use mood boards I've done quite a few
radio interviews about why mood boards
are so successful why people who have
everything tend to have mood boards now
the mood board I made years ago I put it
above my bed which is an odd thing to do
actually because I face away from it so
I don't look at it every day anymore but
a little while ago I looked at it and I
realized that every single thing I put
on that mood board had come true in fact
when I finished with all the um
things I was going to do as a writer I
put up some pictures one was hot air
ballooning and one was something else
and I realized that every single thing
I'd put up I think one was riding a
camel I'd actually done all of those so
I thought well I better make a new mood
board now with new things I want I wrote
down some of the countries I wanted to
go to
so if you put it above your bed do make
sure that you look at it better to put
it really on your fridge or in your
kitchen or in your office you can also
take a big photograph of it and make
that your screen saver and the wallpaper
on your phone because then of course you
will look at it every day over and over
again but even though I made that mood
board and put it in a place where I
didn't look at it and actually looked
away from it guess what it still worked
so imagine how it will work if it's
right in your line of vision if it's on
your computer screen and I work with
many many women who are having huge
problems conceiving and I get them to
make a baby board same thing but it's a
picture of a positive pregnancy test
colored into yes it's lots of pictures
of babies
I have them also put that on Instagram
and on their computer screen so they see
it every day and the success rates with
using that baby board are
phenomenal make your mood board use it
look at it it will really help you take
action because it will excite your
imagination it will motivate you also to
make sure you're actually taking action
after watching this video I've designed
a special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there shift number four is be in the
present moment with Eckhart Tolle the
eagle lives in an uh almost continued
new sense of not enough we could say a
sense of lack
it may not be always in the foreground
but it's always in the background at
least that sense that you're not
complete you don't have enough you are
not enough you are not fully yourself
that you're not fully yourself yet
which of course is true on the human
level
because on the human level you can
always achieve more you can attain more
you can experience more
but it's not true who you are who or
what you are in the essence of your
being in the essence of your being
you're already complete so there are
there's the depths Dimension to who you
are
and there is the service Dimension we
are the surface Dimension is the ego the
ego comes from a place of lack
and whatever you attain through the ego
and the ego
there are the ego has us access to some
power obviously it's the form that
Consciousness has taken
but you're much less powerful Creator as
as an eagle compared to what you could
be you know if you're aligned with the
essence of who you are and you're coming
from a deeper place
that is in alignment with what the
universe wants and where the universe is
going which is
greater consciousness
so if you come from the ego there's a
sense of lack
you always know it retrospectively that
after you have attained something
through egoic
endeavors
if you haven't attained it
then
sooner or later and usually sooner
it does not satisfy you
whatever you attain the moments of
satisfactions are fairly brief
and then again you fall back into the
state of lack and dissatisfaction so no
matter what you create from ego and
through ego
it won't satisfy you now you may not
know this while you're engaged in the
process
but retrospectively you can always know
it
in while you are creating though there
are also certain signs that are
indicative that the ego
has gained the upper hand even if you
might even have started your
manifestation from a deeper place and
then suddenly something happened and the
ego started to take over and so for
example a good sign is that when you
no longer enjoy what you're doing you
engage in a creative process you're
active
you believe that you can achieve it but
the time comes when you suddenly realize
you don't enjoy the work anymore
and whenever an obstacle appears because
in any creative process even though it
may be empowered
you will still occasionally encounter
obstacles to anybody who has created
something new in this world has
experienced that yes you are assisted
the more you are aligned with the depths
of who you are the greater the
assistance you get nevertheless
even in those cases you will encounter
when you create something new you will
encounter obstacles because
the world
there are certain structures in the
world that don't want to change they are
against change
there's a certain
um
in NASA in the structures of this world
and if you want to bring about something
new then sometimes you could come up
against that and some of the inertia
manifest through human beings we don't
want the change that you are trying to
bring about so when you encounter
obstacles as you are bound to
when you're coming from ego you will be
upset and you will regard the obstacle
as an enemy and you would start
complaining or you will become
discouraged you will might become
aggressive you may become stressed you
can't sleep anymore
so you're finding the obstacles create a
um dysfunctional state within you and
then your entire work it becomes a
source of stress for you
and when stress arises it means the ego
is there and is interfering even if your
initial attention might have been very
good you say but for example
I want to create a great spiritual
center where people come to and learn to
be more conscious now what could be
better than that and then that's great
so the intention is great it might be
the initial intention
may be absolutely wonderful but as you
start working then without you knowing
it
the ego can come can creep back in and
claim first of all it says that you are
in desperate need for this to happen and
you cannot be fulfilled and happy unless
this happens it's that these are the
first thoughts that come they may not
become conscious or at the back of your
mind this feeling arises so you
desperately need this to happen every
obstacle in every person who represents
this obstacle becomes and becomes an
enemy and you get upset when you
encounter encounter them so
the and so you you know without you
knowing it you fall back if you fall
into a state of
uh of lack of neediness of not enough
of the
the place you want to get to the aim the
the intention uh
becomes so important to you where you
need to get to the end result that you
want to achieve
become so important to you that
you neglect
the importance the primary importance of
the present moment and your State of
Consciousness in the present moment
so instead of focusing on the step
you're taking at this moment and giving
you utmost attention to what you're
doing now and if you do that you'll
actually enjoy what you're doing instead
of that you're excessively focused on
the desired outcome and the present
moment is no more than an inferior
moment towards this imagine future
moments so your fault if these are all
egoic patterns that you fall back into
and that is well it can become very
frustrating just so a good intention is
not enough you need to be conscious
throughout the create creative process
because the ego can creep back in during
the creative process without you knowing
it shift number five is plant the right
seed David kneltzer the dichotomy of how
things are harvested in your life how do
you manifest what you want right how do
you create what you want we're part of a
creating field and people get in their
own way because they don't realize they
can create whatever they want they're
part of the creation right and creation
to me
is pretty simple
and it fits right in is the first thing
you need to do is to create something it
starts with a seed
[Music]
right so if I want to grow something if
I want to create something there has to
be a seed a seed of thought
corn seed right a watermelon seed a
sunflower seed there has to be a seed
even human beings a seed is planted
that's how we create whether we're like
Corey and I people who manage a ton of
younger people that go with hold on I'm
just planting a seed I don't expect a
harvest today I have to have patience I
have to have perspective I have to stay
positive right because I want to plant
the right seeds because what I see
people doing whether it's the young
people not knowing they're planting
seeds for their future or old people who
are planting seeds for other people's
future and their own
they're planting the wrong seeds they're
voting for the wrong things and then
keep on voting for the wrong thing they
keep planting corn and they're wondering
why they want watermelon but they keep
getting corn
because all they're doing is keep
planning these seeds
[Music]
so how do we plant seeds well the first
way we plant seeds is the most powerful
way is our imagination
right our imagination
it instantly is the seed
when we imagine something we have a
mathematical advantage over where we
were we start over here the big zero
nothing the minute we think about what
we want not why we want it
what we want the why is easy I'm here
and I know I tell people this all the
time everybody knows their why your why
is to help somebody or something I don't
know what it is
but your why is the help
that's what motivates you pursues you
what does that mean our why is to create
a stronger connection to that which
inspires us to feel more connected the
way that we feel more connected to each
other into everything is by giving and
helping that's your why where you get
confused and where everyone gets
confused is we don't know our what the
second step
is nurtured by their own activity and
you as a leader can nurture other
people's ideas as well
you can't just plant a seed and it grows
to a tremendous amount the day you plan
it
so many people especially young people
think that's it I'm overnight success
big projects 10 years five years two and
a half years I always say you're 17 and
a half years from being overnight
success in a real business
that's what it takes some can beat it
some can but that's what takes to seed
and fertilize it so that it harvests
write it it's there
and then it can continually grow and
grow and grow as well there's things you
can do to kill the Harvest but we'll get
there
so it's important to know how many seeds
what seeds how we're doing that but it's
also how we nurturing our seeds
in ourselves and in other people and
shift number six the last one before
some very special bonus Clips is
overcome your limiting beliefs with
Rhonda Byrne I have this is a question
from Instagram
I have read all the series of the secret
many times including the Greatest Secret
my question is even after awareness
which is the greater secret I'm finding
it difficult to manage one strong belief
that I have that if I miss an
opportunity which matters a lot to me
then it takes years to get me another
opportunity how should I tackle this
belief and manifest a new belief
well you know there's two ways that you
can do this but I just think if you just
let that belief go the the first thing
that's so amazing and that I want to
congratulate you for is that you've
realized that's a belief that's
fantastic because when you can see that
something is a belief you have actually
um collapsed half of that belief half of
it so I mean that's amazing and now all
you have to do is have the other half go
away too so what I'm going to suggest to
you is is so that you that belief can
just completely be gone and you you and
you don't have to replace it with
another belief because once it's gone
it's gone now that there are two ways
you could you could create another
belief to override it and that's what is
in the secret you think lots of positive
thoughts and then that will override the
old belief
um but you have to kind of stay on that
track of thinking those positive
thoughts you can't let the other
thoughts come in otherwise the old
belief will begin to override again so
my suggestion is let's just take that
belief let's cut it right
and and for anybody who has any belief
that they don't want like for example
I'm limited there are only a certain
number of things that I can do
[Music]
um I can't do I can't do that I can't do
anything that I want I can't have
anything that I want I can't be anything
that I want if you have if you have any
of those beliefs then you could do this
too so
all you need to do is welcome the belief
that you don't want and for this person
this is what you're really going to find
interesting
is that this person says that they have
a belief that they're finding it
difficult to manage one strong belief
that if I miss an opportunity which
matters a lot to me then it takes years
to get another opportunity so the belief
that the person has is if I miss an
opportunity which matters a lot to me
right and so what I want you to do and I
wish I could say your name but it's
maherto forum
whatever that is okay
um so what I want you to do
and this is what my teacher would say to
me welcome wanting to miss opportunities
that matter a lot to you
and you're like what
but if you welcome
wanting to miss opportunities that
matter a lot to you and then welcome the
feelings that you have of wanting to
regress and welcome any feelings of
regression now that seems totally
contradictory right but let me explain
because it's not why would you want to
miss opportunities that matter a lot to
you well actually
the fact that you have a belief of that
means that somehow
somehow you have thoughts that got into
your subconscious mind that formed a
belief and you know that otherwise you
wouldn't have this belief at all and so
you definitely have it your subconscious
mind thinks you want this thinks you
want it it's got it all wrong but it got
some thoughts in it and it just accepted
it and it was maybe when you were a
child or you heard somebody say
something and you just accepted it and
so that's how we know that we need to
take this belief out and if you welcome
wanting to miss opportunities that
matter a lot to you if you welcome it
you release it
you release it so welcoming is just like
opening up like this welcoming with your
arms out kind of like this
and just welcoming that
and when you walk in that you have
releasing that belief
so incredible really it's so easy it's
worth the effort it really is worth it
because
any negative subject any negative
feelings any belief that you don't want
that's it that's the one practice that's
why it's in The Greatest Secret in my
latest book The Greatest Secret this is
the most important thing you could ever
do I've been doing it now for since I
met my teacher which was in 216
2016. I just don't have I can't even
find a belief I'd love to find one I'd
love to find one because I'd love to get
it you know but uh uh so everything that
we're experiencing is because somehow
our subconscious mind thinks we want it
incredible right there are some things
we don't want at all but our
subconscious mind thinks we do want it
we have inadvertently believed something
so that's why you welcome wanting
something you absolutely don't want
because you're releasing the hidden
beliefs that are causing it
when you have a goal in your head it's
not even a goal it's a fantasy it's a
dream when you have a book like this and
you can call it your goal book and you
write out your goals and you go through
I'm just about to take you through bit
by a bit stage by stage you go back to
that but you can look at it you can
touch it you can just make it real so
remember if you do not write out your
goals as a plan and write out how to
accomplish them you didn't have a goal
you have a wish you have a dream you
have a Daydream if you want to go get a
pen get a nice little book like this you
can do it on your phone too you can make
a document in your computer
and be prepared to make your goals real
so let's start now get your book pause
this if you need to go and find one
create one and I want you to pick a goal
and do not even start with I want to
lose five pounds I want more money these
are what I call wishy washy girls no if
you can make your goals real you might
as well make them huge big enormous
phenomenal so if you say well I want
more money that's why I could go hang on
a minute hey I got ten dollars here
there you go you go well that's not my
goal but you said I want more money and
I learned this almost to work with women
who were infertile that come and go you
know I just want to be pregnant I want
to be pregnant so bad if I was just
pregnant I go well as I look at your
notes you've been pregnant six times I
know I keep miscarrying
so being pregnant is not your goal is it
what
isn't your goal to carry to full term a
healthy robust bouncing baby to deliver
a perfect baby to be a great man yeah
that's my goal why don't you say that
because you can be pregnant lots of
times and never have a baby or you can
say my goal is to have a perfect baby
how about this my goal is to get lots of
attention for what a nervous twitch
explosive gas that will give you
attention but that's not what you want
is it nobody wants explosive gas
so let's start with a big goal pause if
you need to
take some time open your book
and write out a big goal now you can
have a career goal on whatever I'm going
to have my own company create my own
business invent something you can have a
relationship goal my relationship is
wonderful we grow in loving and respect
each other and you can have a health
goal
but I want you to pick one only one not
three not five not ten one goal it can
be career it can be health
can be love pick one goal
and then I want you to decide why you
want that goal so much so the first
thing is I have a goal I want to have my
own business that's my goal and now
you're going to go to a next page and
write out why do you want to have your
own business so much and the more
reasoned you can write out why the more
likely
you will make that goal real so write
down why write down as many why's as you
can remember
you can come back any time to this and
think oh I thought of another why and
another why so leave plenty of space
take your time and when you've done your
whys go to another page and write out
who will benefit from you achieving that
goal of course you will but who who will
benefit for instance if you have your
own business
you will employ people who will benefit
maybe your kids will go to private
school maybe your business will allow
you to help your partner have their
business
the more people who will benefit from
you achieving your goal the more reasons
you have
to achieve that goal so write out who
will benefit from you achieving a who
how and why will they benefit you're
going to buy your mama house put your
niece and nephew through private school
did you think of your mind as like the
genie in a bottle that says your wish is
my command
and I want you to understand that every
thought you think and every word you say
is a blueprint that your mind body and
psyche must make real so when you write
out your goals don't say I wish I could
be rich I long to be in a loving
relationship write it as if it's already
happening I am a millionaire I am in a
loving relationship I go that doesn't
make sense it does make sense because
your mind only works in the present
tense when you say next year I'll have a
bikini body it doesn't know what next
year is
and so you must write your bows in the
present tense I am I always I have I do
this new page is about your discipline
how many hours a day you're going to
spend working on your goal
how often are you going to come back to
this book and look at it I want you to
write out I am
I always I have I do and I want you to
fill that in
you see the best goal in the world will
not work if you don't work and many
people fail at this point they write out
a goal my goal is to be a millionaire my
goal is to be famous my goal is to be
wildly in love and I think that's it
it's not and if you want to be madly in
love right are all the reasons why but
then you have got to put yourself in
front of the kind of person you want to
share your life with
if you want to start your own business
and you have a reason why you also need
to have the discipline to meet people
who will fund you sponsor you joint
venture with you so I want you to really
understand that the best goal will not
work if you don't work you can have the
start point
but you have to keep going many of the
most successful people ever say well you
know I had a goal Luther Vandross had a
goal to be a rock star
and people said well you're an overnight
success you went I don't think so you
know I sang Jingles for KFC for 12 years
that's a long night 12 years and people
said but Luther you're singing on
television that's cool you get paid a
lot of money for KFC I said yeah but
it's not my goal and he stuck it out and
many people have got so close to success
and had to keep going and you have to
keep going so
look at your disorder and decide you
will give more to your goal give even
more work on it look at it write it out
think about it talk about it you must be
prepared to give so much to your goal in
fact you must be prepared to be
unstoppable in the pursuit of your goal
you ever noticed that some people seem
to want to hang on to stuff that is
bothering them they're forever talking
about it they don't want to let it go
they've had a a failure at something and
it's grown they can't get over it they
just can't get over it or somebody said
something nasty to them they don't want
to let it go
do you know what we should do we should
ask ourselves everything that happens is
this serving me
is this serving me and if it's not
serving you get rid of it
you don't want anything in your life
that's not serving you that's not
causing you to grow that's not adding to
the quality of your life
I don't care what it is you will sign
some people they just hold on to bad
stuff they hold on to problems they
don't want to seem to let it go thank
you
and that adds more problems whatever you
focus on grows the only thing that can
grow is the thing you give energy to why
would you hold on to anything that's not
serving you now I want you to think
about this I'm not going to talk about a
lot about this today because I don't
think I have to I just want to let you
know that if you're holding on to
something that does not serve you you
are making a terrible error it's going
to cause all kinds of problems you may
blame other people or other things you
may blame the situation
it's you are the cause of the problem
demanded
told me to pick up this book and read it
Ray Stanford he had a saying he used to
say to me Bob you're the only problem
you'll ever have and you're the only
solution
I think it might have taken me five
years to understand that but I do
understand it
and you know something
I am the only problem I'll ever have and
I am the only solution
don't hold on to anything that is not
serving you rejected
if you know the beautiful part about
having an inductive reasoning Factor
that's the part that chooses thoughts
you can accept or reject the beautiful
part of your mind you can accept or
reject anything that comes into your
world except to reject it it's a choice
don't hold on to anything that is not
serving you you have to be all in and
it's the hardest thing to do because if
it fails then you can feel like a
failure
um you know I think of this idea of
performance necessity
um two stories kind of come to mind one
is I was working with an Olympic gold
medalist Sprinter and we're in the
tunnel and we're going out and he's
talking about the competition and we get
out to the blocks and I said uh he was
really worried about the competition I
said well how do you even gauge like who
who who's going to win you know in in
his particular race people are winning
but by you know one one hundredths of a
second tenths of a second I mean these
are really close Sprints and I said well
how how do you know I said who would you
even bet on
and he says you know I would bet on the
guy
who gets down at the blocks
gets himself settled looks at the finish
line then says
I gotta do this
for my mom
and I was like oh
that's good his performance necessity in
that is it's necessary for him to win
that race for his mom
I think of you know when I started
my career and I I really decided to go
all in with writing and online training
this is like 2000 probably six uh I'd
gone broke completely bankrupt and
failed I left my corporate job I had
this cushy kind of corporate job as a
consultant good job left it to right and
I didn't know how to make it as a writer
I want to do seminars workshops didn't
know how to do that so I was pretty much
a hot mess ran out of money
um I got nothing to my name nothing kind
of no positive prospects no one's
calling me except the guys who want the
money and um
one night I'm writing and the
apartment's so small on the bed I had uh
all you know what my bills my vision
boards all my research all my journals
like the bed was basically the desk the
extended desk and my lady comes in
Denise and she walks past me but she
sees I'm like trying to write so it
doesn't want to disturb me she goes
crawls under
um the covers of the bed
and I'm just typing kind of casually
typing away
and I look over
and
I see my woman
sleeping under my bills
and it was just like
you know because none of us want to see
our you know
our families suffer because we are
not performing sure
and um
I was just like
how to figure this out
and I'm telling you I wrote more that
night than any night in my entire life
next day I wrote more than ever that
Bird's life's golden ticket which came a
bestseller and in you know 18 months
later because I was like I'm gonna
figure out this online thing I mean
throughout marketing I'm gonna figure
out how to teach I'm gonna how to train
and get paid for it because I've never
really been paid for those things I said
I'm going to figure out this industry
and I'm gonna make it 18 months later
after her
crawling under the bills I made 4.6
million dollars Jesus online
Total Transformation people like how did
you do it I'm like she gave me and she
was my necessity I was not going to let
my woman be in that situation
um and she believed in me she supported
me she married me and uh you know but
that was she was my drive
and the second part was I went all in
with my identity I said I am going to be
a great writer
and I am going to be one of the greatest
online trainers there ever was
you know as you said in the intro now
we've graduated over 2 million people
have taken our online courses video
series now I don't think it would have
happened if I hadn't had the guts and
maybe
the no other choice right
right to say this is who I'm going to be
and I'm going to build into that
and it is necessary for me to become
that person so let's go have you ever
spent any time wondering how does
everything happen
how does everything happen why does the
night follow the day
why doesn't the day follow the day
in fact in some places it does
but
I spend a lot of time thinking about
this
after times it almost drives me crazy
the my greater side of my studio here is
a Japanese maple tree and there's times
of the year it's absolutely beautiful
in the spring of the year it has buds on
and then the buds cologne and leaves pop
out and the leaves generally in the
spring are a very deep greeny Brown
they're not a pretty looking leaf
but then they start to change and over
time you don't notice it happening just
one day you look and it's a different
color
and by fall
the leaves are crimson red they're the
most beautiful it is the most beautiful
tree and it's right outside of my studio
I'm sitting here at my desk and
cameras around me but how dare it is
that tree
and you know every fall the leaves turn
red
Every Spring there are greeny brown
they're not greeny brown in the fall and
red in the spring they're always red in
the faux and greeny brown in the spring
think about it did you ever wonder
why the tide goes way out the tide comes
way back in
I spent some time in the Navy in Canada
I was down on the East Coast for a while
and I was near the Bay of Fundy do you
know the Bay of Fundy has one of the
highest and lowest tides in the world
it's absolutely amazing it goes way out
and then comes way back in
same up around Prince George on the West
Coast
you go onto a ship and you might be
walking up a plank just right straight
up and you go off the ship sometimes
you're going right down that ship goes
way up in the air and it comes way down
very high very low tide now some place
the tides not very big they do have a
tide but not too high not too low
why is it so different in one place than
another
you know why does the leaves change
color
why do they change color
you know why does the grass keep growing
wouldn't it be so much nicer if the
grass just you know just stayed at a
certain length you wouldn't have to cut
it but it would always look pretty
you know
do you ever think about this do you know
that everything in this universe happens
in an exact way
and exact way not by chance but in an
exact way
when John Kennedy the president of the
United States actor asked Dr Warner Von
Braun who was The Mastermind behind the
space program we asked him what would it
take to build a rocket that would carry
a person to the moon and bring him back
safely to Earth Vaughn Brown answered
him in five words the will to do it
that's it the will to do it
he knew he didn't have to know how to do
it he knew he had to learn how to do it
but he didn't have to know to make up
your mind you were going to do it now
why did he say that because he
understands the laws
Vine brown one time said after years of
studying the spectacular Mysteries of
the cosmos he was led into a firm belief
in the existence of God and he said the
natural laws of this universe are so
precise that we don't even have any
difficulty building spaceship we send
people to the moon and we can find the
landing with the Precision of a fraction
of a second
now he said these laws must have been
set by someone I see the laws as God's
modus operandi but I'm going to tell you
something everything happens by law when
you and I get in harmony with the law I
never do that odds are pretty good we
should understand them but when we get
in harmony with the law then I'm going
to tell you it's just smooth sailing
success
happens
probably be a good understanding good
idea to understand the laws wouldn't it
think about it
your life is governed by laws that are
not man-made so they're not going to be
man changed and if you study them and
work in harmony with them I'm going to
go shock yourself with the good you can
do now I've been doing that for the last
58 years I'm starting to get a really a
reasonable grip on them but I don't
understand them as well as I want to or
would like to
but I'm going to study a little more
today you know I get my trusty book out
here I'll have to talk to you about this
part that'll be another talk
study the laws find out what they write
what they're like
what are the laws and then study them
you'll win everything we as human beings
have created
on this planet
but essentially fast created in our
minds
all that you see which is human work on
this planet first
[Music]
found expression in the mind then it got
manifested in the outside world
the wonderful things that we have done
on this planet
and the horrible things that we have
done on this planet both have come from
the human mind so if we are concerned as
to what we create in this world it's
extremely important that first of all we
learn to create the right things in our
mind how we keep our minds
if we do not have the power to keep our
minds the way we want it
what we create in the world is also
going to be very accidental and
haphazard
so learning to create our minds the way
we want is the basis of creating the
world the way we want
there is a wonderful story in the yogic
law
on a certain day a man took a walk
he went for a long walk
accidentally unawares he walked into
Paradise fortunate isn't he
just took a walk and he landed up in
Paradise
after this long walk he felt
a little tired
so he thought oh I'm tired I wish I
could rest somewhere
he looked around there there was a nice
tree
underneath which there was
very cushiony grass
so it was inviting he went and put his
head down there and slept
after a few hours he woke up
well rested and he thought oh I am well
rested but I'm feeling hungry I wish I
had something to eat
and he thought about all the nice things
that he ever wanted to eat in his life
and instantly all those things appeared
in front of him
you need to understand they have the
services like that
[Music]
people don't ask questions
food came and he ate
stomach became full
then he thought
oh my stomach is full I wish I had
something to drink
all the nice things that he ever wanted
to drink
he thought about it and all of them just
appeared
drinking people also don't ask questions
so he drank
now with a little bit of alcohol in him
you know Charles Darwin told you all of
you are monkeys your tail fell away not
me Charles Darwin told you that you were
all monkeys and your tail fell away and
then you became human yes definitely the
tail fell away but the monkey
in yoga we always refer to an
unestablished mind
as merkata which means a monkey
why we are referring to the Mind as a
monkey is
what are the qualities of a monkey
one thing about a monkey is its
unnecessary moment
[Music]
and another thing about the monkey is if
I say you're monkeying somebody what
does it mean imitation
monkey and imitation have become
synonymous
so these two essential qualities of a
monkey are very much the qualities of an
unestablished mind unnecessary moment
you don't have to learn it from the
monkey you can teach it to the monkey
and imitation is full-time job of the
Mind
so when these two qualities are on a
mind is referred to as a monkey
so this monkey became active within him
he just looked around thought what the
hell is happening here
I asked for food food came
I asked for drink drink came
there must be ghosts around here
and ghosts came
oh the ghosts have come they're going to
surround me and torture me he thought
immediately the ghosts surrounded him
and started torturing him
then he started screaming in pain and
said oh they're going to kill me and he
died
just now he said he's a fortunate being
the problem is he was sitting under a
kalpa rickshaw or a wishing tree
he asked for food food came he asked for
drink drink came he asked for ghosts
ghost came he asked for torture torture
came he asked for death death happened
now don't go looking for these kalpa
rukshas in the forest you can barely
find a tree
these days
a well-established mind
a mind which is in a state of samyukti
is referred to as a cultivation
if you organize your mind
to a certain level of organization
it in turn organizes the whole system
your body your emotion your energies
everything it's organized in the
direction
once all these four dimensions of you
your physical body
your mind your emotion and the
fundamental life energies are organized
in One Direction once you are like this
anything that you wish happens without
even lifting a little finger actually
it would help to assist it with activity
but
even without doing any activity you can
still manifest what you want if you
organize these four dimensions
in One Direction and keep it unwavering
in that direction for a certain period
of time
right now the problem with your mind is
every moment it is changing its
direction
it is like you want to travel somewhere
and every two steps if you keep changing
your direction the question of you
reaching the destination is very remote
unless it happens by chance
so organizing our minds and in turn
organizing the whole system
and these four basic dimensions of who
you are right now in One Direction if
you do this you are a kalpa Brookshire
yourself
anything that you wish will happen
but right now if you look at your lives
everything that you have wished for till
now if it happens you're finished
everything and everybody that you have
desired for if all of that lands up in
your house today could you live with
that
once we're empowered like this it's very
important
that our physical action emotional
action mental action and energy actions
are controlled and properly directed
if it is not so we become destructive
self-destructive right now that is our
problem the technology which is supposed
to make our life beautiful and easy has
become the source of all the problem
that we are destroying the very basis of
our life which is the planet
so what should have been a boon we are
making a curse out of it
what has brought incredible levels of
comfort and convenience to us in the
last
100 years or so has also become a threat
to our life simply because we are not
conscious action we are in a compulsive
state of action
so organizing our minds fundamentally
means moving from a compulsive state of
activity to a conscious state of
activity
you might have heard of people
for whom they asked for something and
beyond all expectations it came true to
the true for them generally this happens
to people who are in faith
now let's say you want to build a house
if you start thinking oh I want to build
a house to build a house I need 50 lakhs
but I have only 50 rupees in my pocket
not possible not possible not possible
the moment you say not possible you are
also saying I don't want it
so on one level you're creating a desire
that you want something on another level
you're saying I don't want it so in this
conflict it may not happen
someone who has some faith in a God or
in a temple or whatever
who is how simple-minded Faith Works
only for those people who are
simple-minded thinking people people who
are too much thinking for them it never
works a childlike person
who has a simple faith in his God or his
Temple or whatever
he goes to the temple and says Shiva I
want a house I don't know how you must
make it for me
now in his mind there are no negative
thoughts will it happen will it not
happen is it possible is it not possible
these things are completely removed by
the simple Act of Faith
now he believes Shiva will do it for him
and it will happen
[Music]
so is Shiva going to come and build your
house no I want you to understand God
will not lift his little finger for you
what you refer to as God is the source
of creation
as a Creator he has done a phenomenal
job there's no question about it could
you think of a better creation than this
is it in anybody's imagination to think
anything better than what is there right
now
so as a Creator he has done his job
wonderfully well
but if you want life to happen the way
you want it because right now the very
Crux of your happiness and your
well-being is this
if at all if you're unhappy
the only and only reason why you're
unhappy is life is not happening the way
you think it should happen
that's all it is
so if life is not happening the way you
think it is it should happen you're
unhappy if life happens the way you
think it should happen you are happy
it's as simple as that
so if life has to happen the way you
think it should happen first of all
how you think
with how much Focus you think how much
stability is there in your thought and
how much reverberance is there in the
thought process will determine whether
your thought will become a reality or is
it just an empty thought
or
how you do not create any impediments
for your thought by creating negative
thought process
this possible is something possible or
not possible is destroying Humanity
what is possible and not possible is not
your business it's Nature's business
your business is just to strive but what
you want your personality literally ad
is made up of how you think how you act
and how you feel
and how you think how you act and how
you feel is your personality and your
personality is intimately connected to
your personal reality your life so then
if you want to change your life your
personal reality you got to change your
personality and here we go again you got
to start becoming conscious of your
unconscious thoughts you got to start
noticing how you act how you speak you
got to pay attention to how you're
feeling some people would live in guilt
their whole entire life and don't even
know it's guilt because at least it
feels like them so then when you start
doing that you begin to objectify your
subjective self so so then
when you begin to make small changes
back the thought a new thought should
lead to a new Choice a new Choice should
lead to a new Behavior a new Behavior
should create a new experience and a new
experience should create a new emotion
yes and that new emotion is teaching
your body chemically to understand what
your mind is intellectually understood
now your body is embodying the truth
right so then the new emotion should
Inspire new thoughts and that's called
Evolution so how do we get stuck
it's really simple
the stronger the emotion you feel from
some event in your life be it a betrayal
or a trauma or whatever yes the more
altered you feel inside of you the more
you pay attention to the cause outside
of you so the brain takes a snapshot it
freezes an image and embosses that
pattern neurologically in the brain
that's called a memory so we create
long-term memories from strong emotional
events okay so is that true that I just
want to understand the maybe the larger
the event in terms of its emotion to the
stronger of a hold it has over you yeah
well the more it's embossed in your
biology so some certain people have a
strong experience in their life and it
catches all of the brain's attention so
now they think neurologically within the
circuits of the past experience and they
feel chemically within the boundaries of
those emotions and so how you think and
how you feel creates a state of being
now here's the problem
that if you don't know how to mediate or
control your emotional reaction to that
event and you keep that refractory
period of chemicals going on extended
periods of time so that the event
produces a chemical change and the body
needs to return back to homeostasis or
balance but if it can't then the
elongation of that emotional reaction
for weeks say for days or weeks is
called the moon so you say Ed what's
wrong with you I'm in a mood why are you
in a mood well this thing happened to me
five days ago and I'm having one long
emotional reaction so then what you do
is you keep telling the story about it
keep firing and wiring the same circuits
and you keep conditioning the body into
the past so then you wake up in the
morning you look for the emotion
so then now all of a sudden you keep it
lingering for for for weeks or months
that's called the temperament well why
is he so angry I don't know let's ask
him why are you so angry well this thing
happened to me eight months ago I'm
having one long emotional reaction I'm
memorizing my emotions you keep it going
on for years on end that's called a
personality trait so then a person then
is memorizing themselves by living in
the past and so then you say to them
well tell me the story now the latest
research on memory says that 50 percent
of what we talk about in our past isn't
even the truth so we make stuff up about
the past in other words people are
reliving a life that they didn't even
have just to reaffirm that they can't
change right wow so then what's the
significance of this where you place
your attention is where you place your
energy period yes so then the stronger
the emotion that you have the some
problem or condition or person in your
life the more you're paying attention to
them so they captured your attention so
you're giving your power hour away wow
to that person right because they're
capturing your attention so then there's
an energetic connection to every person
everything everything in your past
present reality has your energy
connected to it so now this is the
significance when a person really
decides to be defined by a vision of the
future instead of the memory of the past
the hardest part about it is all of a
sudden becoming conscious and not making
the same unconscious choice so then
if you lower the volume to your
frustration to your hatred to your anger
if you truly knew how to do that if you
lower the volume to that emotion you
would take your attention off that
person which means you would begin to
break those energetic bonds and now
you're taking your power back yes you're
calling energy back to you and we've
measured this and all of a sudden it
builds this bigger electro magnetic
field around the person's body that's
energy to heal that's energy to create a
new future with right and then if you
didn't want to lower the volume to the
emotion then just take your attention
off the person and every time you take
your attention off the person if you
became conscious of that you wouldn't
feel the emotion now the body though has
been addicted to that emotion because
you're using that person to reaffirm
your addiction to hatred or frustration
and if that person died you'd find
another one so then here you go now so
now you're in a position now where you
begin to lower the volume to that
emotion and the body's going wait a
second you've been you've been doing
this for the last 20 years and all of a
sudden you're just going to stop hating
and the body says well I've been
conditioned this way and conditioning is
based on the past so when the body feels
the the lack of that emotion just like a
drug addict it says hey you're off
schedule here so now the body starts
influencing the mind to think about
experiences that are embossed in the
brain that are based on that emotion so
the emotion now is causing you to think
in the past if we teach a person then
how to trade that frustration or that
hatred for an elevated emotion and
they'll say yeah but you know it was my
ex's fault or I got betrayed by my
partner in business yeah yeah we know
that okay so let's take your partner in
business or take your ex let's duct tape
them put them in a cannon and shoot them
to the moon now what are you gonna do
sooner or later you got to reckon with
yourself and change right so then
teach a person then how to trade that
emotion for an elevated emotion now
trade the emotion for an elevated
emotion right so you're going to give
that up and you're going to practice
feeling gratitude for as an example yes
the person says well I can't feel
gratitude and I say absolutely you can
because you don't practice feeling it
you practice spending most of your time
feeling hatred and frustration so now
it's going to take a little time to
cause that heart of you to bloom or your
heart of yours to bloom once they're
able to feel even the smallest measure
of gratitude where they start feeling
appreciation thankfulness
gratitude its emotional signature when
you when you get something when you're
receiving something
when something has happened to you
uh or when something is happening to you
you say thank you because you're
receiving something so the emotional
signature of gratitude means the event
has already happened where it's
happening to you so the moment you open
your heart and you feel gratitude well
that emotion then is telling the body
that the experience has already occurred
and the thought then can make it into
the body because it's consistent with
the thought so now you're beginning to
program the autonomic nervous system
into a very specific Destiny you got to
maintain that modified State of Mind and
Body your entire day independent of the
conditions in your outer environment
independent of your body's Cravings of
those emotions and habituations and
independent from time and if you can get
ready because something weird or unusual
some synchronicity some coincidence some
opportunity is going to land in your lap
and you didn't have to go and get it yes
it came to you now you're the vortex of
creation so if you say to me well I was
feeling gratitude but then there was
traffic or my co-worker sent me a nasty
email that I would say oh my God God you
mean you're allowing your environment
your outer environment to control how
you feel and think you're back to the
unconscious program that you're the
victim to your life you got it but when
you start producing those outcomes in
your life you're going to pay attention
to what you did inside of you and you're
going to believe more that you're the
creator of your life and less of the
victim of your life you need to create
an environment of Excellence Excellence
most people's environments are not
excellent the people around you the the
videos that you watch the things that
are on your wall the voices that are in
your head you have these moments that
are bold that are courageous that make
you feel Unstoppable and you can do
anything and then you fall back down
because the environment is the thing
that's keeping you small it takes a
giant effort to overcome your
environment you definitely can it's
definitely possible tons of people are
doing it but it takes that giant effort
to say I don't want to stay stuck here
most people stay stuck most people make
minimal minimal minimal improvements in
their life year over year
and if you don't want to stay where you
are right now fast forward to one year
from today you don't want to stay stuck
you want to be in a different place
could actually be physically moving but
a different place in terms of your
finances in terms of your purpose in
terms of how much you're giving and
caring and sharing and the life you want
to build you want to be somewhere
totally different like today this is not
acceptable anymore I accept that this is
where I am right now but where I end up
is not going to be the same spot as
where I am right now right if that's
your commitment the biggest shift that
will help you get from where you are now
to where you want to be is creating that
environment of Excellence what's the
fastest way to learn a language what's
the fastest way to learn Japanese well
it's to go to Japan sure you can read
some books and and you can hire a tutor
and that the more intense it becomes the
more you're actually living it the
faster you're going to pick it up
so if you want to develop the mindset of
the high achiever if you want to become
that person the the people that you look
up to the the whoever of the world like
I want to be the next whoever perfect
that person the more you hang around
with them the more it's going to rub off
on you how they think because how they
think how they act how they behave how
they see the world is very different
than how you see it right now and how
the people around you definitely see the
world right now
so how do you do it how do you start to
become it well
I look at what I'm doing
and this was one of my biggest
challenges when I was getting started
and honestly still in like I think the
biggest problem in the world is a lack
of belief
I'm trying to solve the world's biggest
problem people don't believe in
themselves enough I don't you don't
Oprah doesn't people don't believe in
themselves enough for the next level so
how do you start to believe in yourself
more the thing that helped me the most
was to have these successful people
around me constantly
and so I want to share a few tactics
that I think can really help you that
has really helped me as being the shy
introverted kid who never wanted to be
in front of a camera and was making 300
bucks a month and quit on my business
partner and thought life was over right
to now hear and it's taken me 20 years
to get here so hopefully we can shorten
that path for you if you actually follow
some of the advice in this video
so step number one how do we create that
environment of Excellence
what you feed into your brain really
really really matters
so figure out how you love to learn for
me it's videos I like to see things I
need to be visual if that's you then you
need to have a way to have those videos
coming into your life every day it can
be part of your morning routine that's
why I make this channel part of your
morning routine subscribe to the channel
every morning every weekday we got a new
video out there for you to give you the
shot of espresso to help you but if it's
not my channel it's some other channel
one of my other channels
subscribe to the channels that make you
feel bold powerful Unstoppable give you
hope give you belief in yourself
and then watch that video every day or
listen to that podcast every day or read
that book every day the trick is it
can't be the same book or the the one
video because that one video on repeat
is gonna lose its Effectiveness right
you know what you watch a video gets you
all fired up and then you watch it again
the next day and it's not as like oh
what happened I don't feel as good you
watch it the next day and the feeling's
gone so you can't just read the same
book over and over watch the same video
over and over and over again the key is
to find a consistent source so if you
love this channel you love this video
I'm making other videos just like this
that you can subscribe to if you'd like
an author go find their other books or
go find the people that Inspire them so
that you can read something every day if
you'd like a podcast go find other
podcasts like them so you have something
every day so you you are
manipulating what comes in your head
with intention now
with intention so you're not just
scrolling through things like I am going
to watch one of these videos every day
to slowly shift myself forward because
it'll happen if you love Elon Musk and
you watch Elon Musk every day what will
happen is slowly day by day you will
start to think like Elon Musk it will
happen he will pull you forward you will
start to see the big difference in how
he thinks versus how the people around
you think versus how you think right now
and he will give you more courage and
more boldness and more
a sense of hope and purpose that you can
do it too you'll start to think more
like him so be careful who you pick and
maybe you don't like Elon Musk maybe you
like Kanye West or Oprah Winfrey or
whoever but the more you're around that
person the more you will start to think
like them so you want to put that as
part of your daily routine that every
day because yesterday was a different
day you might have been fired up bold
motivated great but today's today is a
new day
the motivation you had yesterday is
nowhere near what it is right now when
you wake up
right you got the best day of all time
you wake up the next day and it's gone
so how do you keep the consistency the
routine
tell yourself I'm going to watch a video
even when I don't want to even when I
feel low energy even when right all the
excuses we come up with I'm going to
watch a video to get myself into the
state I need to get into because I want
to follow I want to follow my dreams I
don't want to be stuck here anymore
tied to that is then subscribe to the
channels
that make you feel that way so do an
audit
of all of the channels you follow on
YouTube of all the people you follow on
Instagram anywhere you're spending time
on social
do an audit of who makes you actually
feel more bold
and who makes you just waste time or who
makes you feel bad about yourself
there's some people you probably follow
who when you look at their stuff it
actually makes you feel worse about
yourself unfollow those people
immediately right they don't care about
you so why are you caring about them
and then the people who make you feel
better
follow them subscribe to them so that
when you happen to be on the platform
when you happen to be throwing going
through YouTube or Instagram you see
them and it makes you remember why
you're doing what you do so the first
part of it is a habit we are designing
our routines around this and I'm going
to watch a video every day with my
heroes so that they pull me forward
right we're putting it into our calendar
the second part of it is I'm also going
to subscribe to channels and people that
inspire me so that when I happen to be
on the platforms I'm feeding myself with
things that inspire me and lift me up
instead of waste my time or put me down
okay so that habit that environment
really really matters the second part of
environment to create our environment of
Excellence right is the physical
environment so
this office inspires me this office this
was all with intent the people on the
wall behind me we got Steve Jobs AP
giannini my parents
Howard Schultz Kanye West the trophies
uh you know the YouTube stuff the the
getting
my hands wrong here this side you know
the art the art that people drew my book
uh my neck brace from when I broke my
neck like all even the colors on the
wall all of this it inspires me this
inspires me
when I walk into this office I I want to
believe more in myself
I see Steve Jobs staring me down I see
my parents staring me down it's like a
reminder of what I want to do because I
wake up and I and I don't have you know
the the most energy I don't feel super
bold and like let's go take on the day
right I don't have that as soon as I
wake up
but we manufacture it through the habits
and routines but also the actual
physical environment and the beauty
about this is you only have to set it up
once you know I set this up once and
then I walk in and every day I'm being
hit with these messages and reminders of
the person that I want to be so whether
that's a mood board you put up for
yourself where there's people that
inspire you you have to look at the
thing it inspires you to want to push
you a little harder it inspires you to
want to believe in yourself and more it
inspires you to want to go off and take
some kind of action today the physical
environment matters a lot and you can
control that so think about think about
your office think about your bedroom
think about your car think about where
you're spending significant time and how
much of that has actually been done with
intent
how much of your physical environment
has been created with intent to make you
believe in yourself more
it matters a lot and then the third
thing really quick is the actual your
outfit the clothes that you wear how you
show up for yourself when I put this on
I remind myself that I'm a superhero
going to work that might sound really
dumb or cheesy but you know what it
works for me I am a superhero going to
work I'm not fighting crime I'm fighting
lack of belief I want people to believe
in themselves more and I'm going to work
when I see there was a green arrow show
I used to watch
and when they were in their their base
in their Lair they always put their
outfits on a mannequin right so they're
when they're out fighting crime they're
in their uniforms but then when they
come back to their base they're in
normal clothes but they put their
outfits on a mannequin so I went and got
myself a mannequin it's it's just you
can't see it but it's just sitting here
off camera I got a mannequin and it's
got my hoodie on it as a reminder that
I'm a superhero going to work every day
and again that might sound really cheesy
or dumb or corny but I like it it works
for me and putting this on every day
instead of just showing up in my pajamas
I just I work from home
you know we've got 30 something people
on the team uh I I don't see my team
physically that often most people work
from home I could just show up every day
in my pajamas
by putting this on
reminds me that I'm a superhero with a
mission
God is up to you but but
present yourself for yourself not just
for the camera I'm not putting this on
just for the camera I'm putting this on
because it's what I put on this is for
me
I could make a video in my pajamas
that's fine but I'm making this for me I
wear this for me what do you need to do
for you not just because there's some
expectations when your expectations of
yourself become higher than what you
think other people's expectations are
for you that's when the game starts to
change when I'm wearing something just
because of how I think you guys will
perceive me or or some speech I'm doing
or some meeting
I'm I'm only living up to that person's
standard to what I think their standards
are and said no I'm doing this for me I
wear this for me I show up like this
even if I'm not making any kind of
content I only make content once a week
usually for YouTube what are the what am
I doing the other days of the week I'm
still wearing this because I'm a
superhero going to work and it's my
reminder
this is how you start to create an
environment of Excellence guys your
environment is keeping you where you are
your environment is keeping you stuck
and if you don't want to be stuck
anymore if you want to change your
circumstances if you don't want to be in
the same spot you are right now one year
from today you have to create an
environment of Excellence
how do we do that number one we start
feeding our mind with Excellence from
the videos and podcasts and books from
people who Inspire Us number two we
change our physical environment so that
you walk into a room you walk into your
car you walk into your bedroom or office
or wherever you're spending time and it
pushes you forward to step into the
person that you want to be and then
number three The Outfits what you wear
how you present yourself having a higher
standard for yourself than what other
people expect that you are a superhero
going to work every day because you are
on a mission
you've got a great heart you've got tons
of ideas
I see it over and over and over and over
and over again
so much potential
and just stuck
just stuck
because it's a lack of momentum that
stems from having a really poor
environment
if you can just change with intention
that I am going to create an environment
of Excellence for myself that inspires
me and pushes me forward to step into
the person I want to believe that I can
be
you can do that every day
entire life will change
[Music]
because you made it
a video I I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you're different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
it's a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
Below on this video I will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome if you want to learn the simple
techniques to manifest anything check
the video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there what the steps are
that you need to take to get there and
you know how to cook your mind goes
blank if this is you I'm so excited that
you're watching this because the simple
trick based in science is called the
power of objectivity all you gotta do